washington journal continues
welcome back to our newspaper round
table this morning we have uh michael
catanzaro with us from human events and
stephen glass from the new republic
welcome both of you appreciate having
you here today uh mike what are you
reading today uh i was reading a story
on president clinton criticizing the gop
budget plan uh it was drafted by senator
pete domenici
it's sort of interesting to see
president clinton coming out after the
jones decision and really taking it to
republicans on this issue
one of the things he has criticized
republicans for is taking the budget
surplus and using it exclusively for
medicare whereas
president clinton wants to use the money
to fund raft of new social programs
um
from on the republican side there is
some division as well as to what to do
with the surplus
conservatives led by senator john
ashcroft want to use that money for more
tax cuts and actually last this past
thursday they were
very effective in that they got the gop
leadership in the senate to go along
with a larger tax cut of 60 billion
dollars
and that's it's very interesting to see
that the new york times did a story on
this this morning it says that a story
by richard burke
mr clinton castigated senate republicans
for approving a
1.73 trillion dollar spending plan on
thursday night that calls for a modest
tax cuts and virtually and excludes
virtually all of the president's
proposals for new spending and mr
clinton scolded members of the house for
passing a six-year 217 billion dollar
transportation bill packed with projects
for almost every congressional district
what are you reading today oh i'm sort
of troubled today by a star's office
defending the
the subpoena to two bookstores in
washington asking to see which books
monica lewinsky purchased
i think it's clear that it sort of will
place a chilling effect on what people
read if they know that government
investigators could easily
determine that it's sort of it scares me
in some sense do you uh what do you
think about him comparing is the the
lead of the washington post story today
says uh federal prosecutors defended
their scrutiny of monica lewinsky's book
purchases yesterday saying government
investigators had also examined the
reading habits of convicted oklahoma
city bomber timothy mcveigh unibombanter
ted kaczynski and the men convicted of
bombing the world trade center i think
it's a comparison it's an absolutely
ridiculous comparison not only of course
monica lewinsky's not anywhere near
timothy mcveigh or theodore convince
kaczynski but much worse it's logically
misstated because those two inquiries
were to determine if the identification
of the person was correct they used the
books to determine if that the person
they thought had committed the crime
actually was the person who had
committed the crime there's no there's
no question as to whether or not monica
lewinsky was the person involved in this
situation and so using the books is
merely a way to determine what she's
thinking about and i think that's
dangerous what do you think
well
at this point i don't know if we can
really criticize star for what he's
doing i'm not a lawyer uh i don't know
if this is successive or not but uh you
know who knows what star has maybe this
is
uh going to provide him with a clue that
could tie up this case i i really don't
know
do we have any idea why ken starr is
going after these uh books all we know
all we know and of course we don't know
a lot of it is that it seems like
there's
it seems like monica lewinsky gave a
book to the president and presumably
since we know she bought a large number
of books from two book stores in the dc
area that one of those books could
describe their relationship but i think
lots of people one of the books that's
potentially that a book she read is a
book i've read and of course i've had no
no uh illicit relationship with the
president so i think it's very dangerous
to bring connections from what people
read people are allowed to explore free
thoughts um and it'll have a chilling
effect on what people read and what
people think about
speaking of free thoughts uh human
events is the newspaper you work for the
the national conservative weekly tell us
a little bit about the newspaper what is
it
uh human events has been around for
53 or 54 years uh and i just actually
wrote a story this week on
the highway bill that just passed the
house
it's a massive expenditure it's
something around 217 billion dollars
actually that was what was passed in the
house
the senate passed a bill slightly the
last system like 214 billion dollars
uh sort of interesting because this is a
bill that the republican led congress
passed
this is a bill that is 43 greater than a
bill that was passed in 1991 in terms of
spending and there's a record number of
demonstration projects with
demonstration projects are pork barrel
projects as we commonly refer to them
tell us about a couple of them do you
remember any of the ones that are in
there uh yeah there was one
i think it was in pennsylvania to open
up some sort of motor museum and at the
museum they're gonna open they set aside
money for a restaurant and a micro
brewery
uh you know things that really aren't
related to paving roads so it's sort of
interesting um but
one of the things here that republicans
have come under fire from is as i said
the amount of spending and there
president clinton is actually
positioning himself to the right of
republicans and criticizing them for
busting the balanced budget agreement
that was agreed to last summer
i think the house bill breaks the caps
by something like 30 billion dollars so
is that a little bit of a role reversal
for the president in the congress yeah i
think so i think so um the new republic
this uh the latest edition of the new
republic uh story by jonathan cohn
that's your magazine john uh has a story
on um high on the hog everyone hates
pork barrel spending everyone is wrong
have you read this article and what are
they what are they saying there
i think
john cohn makes an excellent point that
uh pork barrel spending
while there are different problems with
pork barrel spending it also provides a
useful function in making the grease
that makes congress run much more
efficiently
and had it not been for pork barrel
spending lots of good programs also
wouldn't be funded and lots of
good legislative agenda agendas could
never actually get through it's
necessary to
sort of keep congressmen working
together
you sound like you're defending the
republican congress there not something
i'd expect a new republic writer to do
no you know i well the republican
congress is not the only one that's
passed pork barrel spending of course
historically um
i think the new republic is a an
interesting magazine in part because it
really is can't be defined as a
democratic or a republican magazine it
sort of tries to call him as a season
right
um there's another article in uh your
paper today on the subject of the uh of
this bill it's about pulse polster who's
a
conservative pollster named
luntz what's his first name frank
frank luntz briefed republican
congressman on pitching the highway bill
as a conservative idea tell us about
this is this or are you uh what's that
conservative idea i we at human events
don't think frank luntz is a
conservative either so uh
i i think it's it's
just outrageous that franklin's would go
around telling republicans to go and
tout this bill as a conservative idea
there's nothing conservative about it
one of the things mr luntz suggests
according to this article is uh that
that in
talking about this bill uh democrats
excuse me republicans make the point
that we can't cure cancer yet but we
already know how to build better safer
roads and prevent injuries all we have
to do is spend the money that's already
there is this money already there
well no they i mean they've actually
broke the balance budget caps as i said
before they were set in the budget
agreement last summer so the money isn't
there and right now the big issue is
finding offsets or cuts to try and keep
this spending within
the balanced budget and president
clinton has gone after republicans on
it's very legitimately saying that you
have not uh followed budget discipline
on this
we're going to go to a caller old
orchard uh beach maine on the republican
line how are you this morning hi thank
you good morning good morning i want to
find out about this phony ssi
i'm a veteran i'm 77 years old
i get a veterans check which i'm
thankful for
now these people on ssi have never done
nothing for the country
now they receive about 500 a month
food stamps
medicaid
and all other benefits
now as a veteran
i receive a check and i have to go
travel 150 miles
to go see a
an intern
without their benefits they can go to
any doctor they want
and get all these rights food stamps and
everything
and never done nothing for the country
now kevin wells done the right thing in
massachusetts
he had them all reexamined
and he took about 40 percent of them off
of ssi
for alcoholics and all that's the
phoniest thing in america
we can receive best benefits as a
veteran
than people that have done nothing for
the country
mike that sounds something like
something you might want to respond to
uh
i'm not too familiar with the program
but i know that uh social security is i
believe supplemental security
supplements yeah that's right
there have been some some problems uh
with the program i know in terms of
fraud and there are people have been
taking advantage of it um
i i think now
some people refer to it as i get my
crazy check every month is
uh
kids will come in and act sort of
in a weird fashion and that will qualify
them as disabled and they will be able
to get a check under ssi and there have
been cases
of abuse
certainly yes
what do you think i i don't know about
people saying they'll get their crazy
check in the mail um
i think there of course are cases of
abuse that doesn't mean you should throw
out ssi and the caller is right that
veterans deserve great benefits and
equal if not better equal benefits to
anyone else but i think the country's
right in having a program that
guarantees sort of
some form of safety net for all citizens
and we contribute to a central pot that
protects us all and makes and generally
makes the economy better
let's take one more call from
jacksonville florida on the democratic
line how are you this morning fine thank
you um
uh the reason i'm calling is about the
japanese economic situation i think it's
really interesting that this should be
occurring
as we approach the 25th anniversary of
nation at risk which launched all the
education reforms uh that this
country is pursuing based on the fact
that germany and japan
were perceived as to be
superior to the united states
educationally and and and that was
attributed to the reason why they
were uh
were able to compete better
than the united states in all the
different markets
i wonder if either of these reporters
have ever read anything called the
sandia report from sandia national
laboratories which trashed the findings
in nation at risk saying that children
weren't
doing as badly in our schools
and
if that is the case it was a report that
was by the way suppressed by the bush
administration
and if that is the case then i think a
lot of the direction that we're taking
in education was based on false
methodology i'm sure we'll be hearing a
lot from bill bennett and a lot of the
people that
that push for the education reforms that
came out of the bush administration i
think there's a different agenda there
where do you come down on education
reform well i think
nation risk came out in 1983
and in that report
i think it was basically concluded that
american education is is in trouble
and i think since 1983 i don't think
much has really happened
there are some interesting experiments
going on in the country
with school vouchers
particularly in cleveland and we've seen
some real success stories there was a
recent harvard study
on the cleveland voucher experiment
showed that test scores are going up
that parents are very satisfied with
their
children's education
and i think this is a great model that
we should pursue because right now i
think public schools have a monopoly and
i think that they are simply not
responding to parents needs to educate
their children um congress is struggling
right now with a uh with i believe a
voucher bill is that going to get
anywhere this year i don't know if
that's going to get anywhere one of the
things they've been doing on the
education front explain explain what
vouchers are first why don't we voucher
simply is the government giving back uh
a certain stipulated amount of money to
parents and says here you can have this
and you can send your child to whatever
school you choose so parents aren't
locked into the system anymore
if you're in the inner city and you're
going to public school a parent can say
well i want to take my kid to a
parochial school in suburbs or a
parochial school in the inner city
right now republicans are their biggest
issue in the education front is pushing
senator paul coverdale's education
savings accounts which would allow
parents to put away i think it's twenty
five hundred dollars in a year and after
tax dollars and they can use that money
towards education expenses have you
followed these issues yeah i followed
some of them i think
he's right that vouchers are an
excellent program to try there's several
problems with them that he's not
addressing though one is that it was
very difficult to work on sort of a
global level or a national level
there's lots of market costs that don't
get seen and small sort of small
boutique studies that and transition
costs that you don't see when you expand
it to much larger populations i think
there's also a fear of people going to
parochial schools and carrying their tax
stars with them the parochial schools
are an excellent system and they've
thrived by using by working off sort of
private contributions and tuition
dollars and i'm not positive that tax
dollars which uh would be diverted to
parochial schools is a good use of both
government resources and uh to bring
down the sort of public sectarian system
farmington new mexico on our independent
line how are you this morning i'm doing
great thank you so much for c-span i
learn a lot i'm really thankful for you
guys thank you for watching um i have an
observation and then i have a question
for both of your guests this is a
political question
and i'm going to read it because i'm
sort of nervous and i want to be precise
here my observation is that republican
philosophy seems to be connected with an
idea that human nature is basically good
and that people if simply left alone by
the government would do the right thing
not only for themselves but for their
neighbors
and democrat philosophy seems to be
rooted in the idea that human nature is
basically flawed and thus that people
need government and laws to sort of uh
define and correct
their behavior
my question for both of you
and i really would like for both of you
to answer it from your individual
perspectives is um
could you sort of define for me what um
uh
the other the other uh
libertarian party what what their
philosophy is and and i'll hang up and
listen for your response
uh let's go to stephen first
i think actually
it was a very thoughtful question um
the philosophies though are slightly
skewed here i think the libertarian
philosophy is actually closer to what
she thought the republican philosophy is
the libertarians believe that people are
inherently good and so left their own
devices will help each other through
charity and provide for themselves thus
providing for the entire common good um
republicans and democrats i think none
of them believe that people are
inherently good and i think they um
they they believe that there's some
flaws and
very very broad strokes and very
generally i think democrats believe that
through
cooperative agreements and working
together we can help each other and
republicans lean more towards uh
individualized behavior but that but i
could be uh that's my own opinion well
uh
liberty well thomas jefferson was a
libertarian uh and he basically believed
as many of the founding fathers did that
human nature is fundamentally flawed
and that's why we do need laws but the
thing that that helps human beings along
is the the nature of the mediating
institution a church or a community
group and that that is what they
principally relied upon
to guide us through our lives
instead of government and i think that's
more in line with what republicans stand
for today limited government allowing
people to take their own initiative and
work in a free market society whereas i
think democrats
want more government intervention in the
economy and want more social programs
that type of thing
do an abrupt shift here and talk about
an article by mr glass steven you did
for uh harper's magazine this month in
which you
posed as a psychic tell us about that
yes i spent a summer working as a
telephone psychic
and
taking calls within one of the psychic
networks that you see advertised on late
night television
how i got involved was very complicated
but and getting the job was very
complicated but slowly over the course
of the summer i rose to being one of the
best psychics in the network and it's
important to stress that i have no
psychic ability whatsoever i think in
fact being a psychic on the psychic
network probably would be detrimental to
the job it just helps to listen to
people and be nice
but the story goes through more how
psychic networks target minorities and
target the poor and make a lot of money
off them um you were telling you you
were saying at the end of the article
that um you got some
sad calls toward the end of your stint
there i think in the beginning it seemed
like a lot of fun you received lots of
phone calls that people who have strange
problems or you know want you to conduct
seances or communicate with the dead and
i was more than willing to comply i had
a woman who would call me regularly and
say she would like if she thought she
was being chased by the cia and she
needed me to talk to her a dead irish
setter named john bones that could watch
from the heavens and see if the cia was
close behind and so of course you know i
would say things well jump bone says
bark woof woof should say that means
they're close and she'd you know move to
another state but as i did this for over
the course of summer i began to realize
that the majority of the calls are not
or close to the majority at least are
people who are seriously emotionally
disturbed often involved in physically
abusive relationships and need serious
help
psychic networks are extremely
profitable
they're growing and are expected to grow
by leaps and bounds until the year 2000
and what they do is take advantage of
people who in society need help can't be
taken advantage of have very little
money and need professional therapy
what was the reaction of your employer
when they found out that you were going
to write an article about this my
employer knew all along that i was a
journalist i told them that my day job
was in the new republic and in fact uh
the chief of psychic affairs there who
handles the psychics uh said that she
could communicate with michael kinsley
who was the once the editor of the new
republic sort of telepathically
mr kinsley never received any such
communication but uh
i double checked i called him up and uh
she said she had problems communicating
with uh the new editor but that's okay
it was a fun story
we welcome your calls uh we're not going
to tell your fortunes however let's go
to hartford connecticut for the on the
republican line how are you this morning
oh i'm fine thank you
my question to both of you is that with
18 months left and about 18 months left
in bill clinton's presidency what do you
think will be his biggest legacy
um
what do you think that bill clinton's
biggest achievement will be
um four or five years from now well i'd
like to have you both comment on that so
thank you question why don't you go
first mike it is a thoughtful question
well i i suppose it all depends on what
happens with ken starr's investigation
um
if bill clinton is impeached from office
i'm not exactly sure what his legacy
will be um i'm not sure if people really
remember him for
any sort of domestic achievements um
certain on the for on the foreign policy
front we haven't seen
anything notable from the clinton
administration that i can think of
um
the only thing i can really think that
bill clinton will be remembered for is
probably an advocate of
of the poor an advocate of advancing
social programs and education uh but
beyond that i can't think of anything
else how about you i think he'll be well
remembered i think he'll remember that
the deficit was erased i think people
will remember that
he made great strides on the race issue
and i also think that bill clinton will
be remembered if he takes positive
reform towards
saving the social security system and so
i think i think actually he'll have a
very nice legacy i don't think it'll be
the legacy of some of the great
presidents as he wishes but i think
it'll be a nice legacy do you think no
matter what happens with ken starr he'll
be remembered for
monica lewinsky paula jones and
whitewater oh yeah but i actually think
in retrospect the future might look uh
sort of poorly on the republicans and
ken starr for this so it may work to his
benefit i think they'll be very worried
about something i'm very worried about
and others are as well which is the
criminalization of sex and i think
they'll see this as
a place the country should not have gone
and hopefully they'll move away from it
let's take another call from myrtle
beach south carolina how are you this
morning i'm fine good morning and thanks
for taking my call a great show as
always and what a pleasure to see two
bright young men like this
our country is well
in hand for the future and my question
is
uh i'm confused on the bill that's going
through the house
and congress
the highway bill with all the polk and
confusion does the president still not
have the line item veto and where is
that can't he acts into that through the
line item veto i think that it's in is
being contested or maybe going to the
supreme court i'm not sure but i think a
lot of us out here confused on it if
you'll tell us why he can't react
through the line item veto and again
thanks for your show
mike do you think he's going to wield
his veto pen on this uh he has in the
past and you know that's this is a great
question because i i'm not sure exactly
where this is in the courts right now
but uh it hasn't been overturned yet
it's right it's working its way toward a
resolution about whether or not it's
going to be overturned so i guess he
could still if he wanted to yeah he's
he's wielded it before in the past i
don't see him hesitating now i mean just
judging by his comments uh this past
week
he certainly isn't happy with some of
the spending in it so
stephen do you think if he does wield
the line item veto he might um politics
might come into play because apparently
there's there's money for every
congressional district he could play
favorites if he wanted to yeah i think
if he uses it at all it'll be extremely
surgically applied and
very fine points
every congressional district benefits
from some aspect of the bill
coming up into an election year
there seems to be no reason to actually
antagonize voters so i he has nothing to
gain really by doing it
um michael want to talk about a little
bit about where you came from
i i was actually born here in washington
dc uh i lived here for about a year with
my family and then we moved to cleveland
ohio where i've lived for about 22 years
uh then i went off to school in new york
city and now i reside here in washington
dc you went to fordham university yeah
what'd you study there uh political
science and philosophy and uh how did
you end up at human events uh actually i
went and did a brief stint at the
national journalism center i was an
economics fellow there for summer and
that's how i came into contact with
human events actually the fellowship was
divided half is doing research in-house
on different topics and the other half
is doing an internship at a news
publication and i did mine at human
events and when my fellowship was
finished they asked me to come back how
long have you been there for
about a year and a half now
stephen where'd you come from how'd you
get to the new republic i originally
came from chicago and i went to the
university of pennsylvania and shortly
thereafter i worked at the associated
press in philadelphia and a paper called
the syracuse post standard and when i
first came to washington i had a job at
a small magazine called policy review
and then was hired out at the new
republic and i've been there ever since
and you write regularly for the rolling
stone magazine what do you do for them i
write most i've written recently on the
drug war and i write uh sort of on youth
culture for rolling stone do you like
that oh it's great fun it's it's a whole
it's another outlet that uh you can't
really write what you write for the new
republic there right george magazine how
is that doing george tell us about
george magazine if our readers don't
know about it and
george magazine is a magazine published
by hachette in new york and it
has a rather famous has a famous head
john kennedy jr and it's a lot of fun to
write there as well
let's take another call from irvine
california the independent line thank
you for calling what's on your mind this
morning uh i'd just like to get back uh
with your two guests there and their
comments on the highway funding bill i'm
a little confused here
they're trying to say or i guess they're
saying that the money isn't there well
i'd like to know what we've been paying
all these gas taxes for all these years
and the money's gone into a trust fund
and i certainly think that that money is
there and i think if you went out and
took a pull of the average american you
would find that 99.99
percent
uh would say that that money should be
spent to repair the roads which are in
complete disrepair
and in fact on c-span about a month ago
the civil engineers society said that
that bill
is probably worth more like a trillion
dollars or 900 billion so spending only
a couple hundred billion certainly isn't
even by their estimate going to uh to
even uh approach what needs to be done
i'd like to hear their comments
who wants to go first mike uh i'll take
it uh actually it's not clear whether
the federal gas tax uh the money they
collect goes actually to fund highways a
lot of it is used to
fund general programs in the government
john kasich actually tried to
in the debate i think was wednesday
tried to bring up an amendment that
would have allowed states just to keep
all the money they put into the fund and
fund their own internal improvements
now
the money really
isn't there in terms of as i said before
that it has broken the budget caps in
the balanced budget agreement so uh it's
busted by like 30 billion dollars so i
think it's sort of irresponsible what
are you uh the the chairman of this bill
the chief proponent bud shuster
has human events been treating him
kindly uh no actually there's an
interesting part of the story uh some
conservative backbenchers steve largent
tom coburn lindsey graham and some
others actually accused
bud shuster of bribing them
they were pretty much opposed to the
bill as it as it was and what what they
allege is that bud shuster came over to
their offices some of the transportation
aides and said that they would give them
more pork barrels
projects if they would just go along
with the bill
and they declined and they went to the
floor and called schuster out and
schuster actually countered and said
it's a blatant falsehood that's not true
but it's an interesting dynamic to the
story
you got any comments on this yeah i
think the bud shooter allegations are
extremely troubling i agree with you
there um and i think i think the caller
misunderstood what both of us are saying
i don't think we're either of us are
saying at least i'm not saying that
there's no money there it's the way the
government has structured its spending
that this seems to exceed that but money
can be found and i think it's a matter
of prioritizing i think this is a very
strong priority what else you all
reading in the paper this morning do you
see anything else interesting mike uh
yeah there was an article on the uh
tobacco bill um
in the washington post
um and what is it what does that say uh
well this has been an interesting fight
uh on capitol hill for some time now
there's a whole bunch of different plans
what
congress is essentially doing is trying
to sign into law an agreement that was
made between tobacco companies
and state's attorney generals last
summer i think it was between 40 states
and the tobacco companies it was a
pretty
landmark settlement
something like 368
billion dollars that will the tobacco
companies will have to pay out in fines
uh now congress is essentially going to
go with that
it's actually the bill that came out of
the commerce committee is far harsher
on tobacco companies than the one that
was agreed to last summer
so this should be an interesting fight
steve what else are you reading this
morning i'm reading the story about
gingrich and his new book
if you may have seen he has this
expansive book tour coming up which
remarkably stops in iowa and new
hampshire uh previous those aren't too
big book markets so i think it shows a
clear sign that gingrich is gearing up
for the presidential bid
you think he's going to run well it sure
seems like he's testing it i mean i most
book tours that i'm aware of they
usually stop in new york l.a los angeles
chicago
they stop you know in cities that where
there's large book populations small
towns in new hampshire generally don't
really capture the entire
not watching new hampshire callers will
call me but
they don't capture enormous amounts of
book readers c-span viewers can
see what newt gingrich has to say about
this at uh eight o'clock tomorrow
tonight on our sister network c-span two
that's the one that normally carries the
senate um and then at noon and six p-m
uh tomorrow on this channel c-span one
mike do you think uh mr gingrich is
gonna run for president does he have
have it in him i think he i think he
will yeah i think he's positioning
himself right now uh to make a run his
approval ratings are certainly on the up
uh he did i think mentioned just a few
days ago that he was going to seek
another term as speaker but uh in
whether or not he will do that
is unclear i think he does have it in
him to make a shot for the presidency
and uh what do you think the
conservative wing of the party would
think of newt gingrich or they are they
happy with him well i think they're very
unhappy with them
but at the same time i think newt isn't
a very effective speaker
i think he's he can lead and i think
they realized that he would be a very
articulate candidate of conservative
principles so
at this point i'm not sure
there are some other candidates you know
dan quayle and steve forbes and i don't
know how they stack up at this point
with gingrich but uh we'll see i think
an interesting aspect that people are
forgetting about this is the way the
republic the house republicans
instituted uh sort of committee term
limits when they first came into power
was that all of the committees will end
now or at the end of this term but the
speakers won't end for another two years
which a lot puts kingridge in a very
special place to be sort of another king
maker he can put all of his people in
place in those committee chairmanships
which will put him in a very powerful
position come the election it'll make
him the strongest at least congressional
or senate candidate um whether steve
forbes of course would be somebody he'd
have to compete with from the outside as
would say jack kemp but it puts him in a
very unusual and uh good position for
himself
what about on the democratic side does
you think al gore has it locked up
i think al gore is clearly the favorite
and i think al gore um
represents sort of the mainstream of the
party i think he has a very good shot
what do you think al gore
i i think yeah i think he's definitely
the front runner at 2000 is going to be
an extremely interesting race on both
sides uh the democratic side i think
it's gonna be interesting fight between
dick kephart and al gore i think al gore
as i said has the lead
uh i think the party will probably go
with them but get part it's definitely
gonna make it make it a tough fight
we have an email this morning from
lenexa kansas and the question from
michael there is do you think the
president might hold out against a river
of negative evidence until january 20th
1999
the midpoint of the term then resign
giving mr gore a chance for two terms
and a total of ten years
well
i don't know if it's a matter of whether
he can hold out it certainly all depends
on what ken starr has
if he brings a report to the house that
that clearly shows that the president
obstructed justice suborn perjury in
person and purging himself uh i i think
that's grounds for impeachment and uh
you know we'll see what happens but uh
he could potentially be out of office
before then i think that
implies lots of planning on their part
which i think this white house has never
been really strong on uh you know
holding out exactly to the day when
corps is allowed constitutionally to
have two-fold terms in addition to
explain that
the caller i was assuming everybody knew
what the point the
nailer was the way the constitution is
structured is you're allowed two full
terms in a maximum of ten years so if
clinton were to resign today and gore to
become president he would be allowed to
finish clinton's term and then only have
one full term of elected presidential uh
having been elected president because
another presidential term would actually
violate the 10-year cap on being
president so only if clinton as the
caller pointed out only if clinton
resigns after mid-january of 1999 can
gore get that maximum 10 years by having
the two years of clinton's term or the
year and a half there of clinton's term
plus his two full years two full terms
it requires enormous planning that i
sure people thought of but i can't
imagine that being the case make it both
go out on a limb here prediction do you
think uh clinton's going to
serve out his term or not most
definitely i think clinton will serve
out his term i think we're seeing a
welcome time this is going to go over to
the congress which is the proper place
according to the constitution for
investigations of the president and it
puts a political puts the political heat
on republicans if they have the goods
they'll make good but if not i think the
country will punish them and i think
that's fair how about you
well i i it's republicans now seem to be
confident that ken starr has something
uh newt gingrich is now actually coming
out and speaking publicly about this for
the first time
so i think if republicans have the
backbone to go through this if there's
something of substance there i i think
they will go forward and i think you
might even see some some democrats and
prominent democrats calling on the
president to resign
let's go to another caller grand rapids
michigan on our republican line how are
you this morning i'm fine thank you this
is ann angstrom
i have two questions that are quite
generic
one is something that i've been
wondering about and haven't heard
anything about and that is uh i
understand of course that the uh uh
the trip was paid for clinton and some
of the people
out of public monies but how there must
have been 30 35 people in that list you
had on c-span including afl uh cio
chief sweeney are you talking about his
trip to africa is that what we're
talking about yeah that's right
and uh who paid the trip for all those
people did they pay it themselves
or did public monies also pay for them
second question very short
i'm an admirer even though i'm a
republic
republican of uh house representative
uh trafficking
who writes his speeches
c-span viewers i'm sure know who
congressman uh traffic ant is uh i'm not
sure who if anybody writes his speeches
i've actually watched him give a few
myself i think he makes them up as he
goes along he gives them some thought
about five minutes beforehand and then
he goes out and with both guns blazing i
think five minutes might be generous
yeah
um the call go to the caller's question
uh the first part of the question that
is a good question i don't know
how uh or who paid for for uh
those people to go on this trip uh for
the second part of the question i think
jim trafficant is
certainly an interesting guy uh i've
seen him on the floor as well and i
don't know who writes his speeches but
they're pretty darn good how's the
president's travel paid for uh well i
know journalists of course
reimburse the white house for their
travel and sometimes corporate
executives uh pay for their travel and
sometimes it's considered part of the
mission so i'm not sure how this exact
trip went often when it's part of the
mission i think it's something the
country should want to pay for it builds
jobs it builds
it represents the us interest abroad
it's not always government officials who
can best represent us interests and so
sometimes it pays to have corporate
executives going with them
we're going to have that's all we have
time for today thank you michael thank
you steven we'll be back after about
five minutes stay with us
[Music]
we'll talk with an oil daily reporter
alan kovsky about u.s oil policy and
opec the organization of the petroleum
exporting countries
first today is the 30th anniversary of
the assassination of the dr martin
luther king and yesterday gerald posner
author of a recent book about reverend
king called the killing dream spoke to
us about the convicted assassin james
earl ray